Now we'll try and understand
Christianity by trying to understand the
concept of God and Christianity. Before
we dwell into the subject, I would like
to make a few points clear. Islam is the
only non-Christian faith which makes it
an article of faith to believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him. No Muslim is a
Muslim if he does not believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon him. We believe
that he was one of the mightiest
messengers of Allah subhanaa tala of
almighty God. We believe that he was
born miraculously without any male
intervention which many modernday
Christians today do not believe. We
believe that he gave life to the dead
with God's permission. We believe that
he healed those born blind and lepers
with God's permission.
The Christians and the Muslims we are
going together. So one but there is
parting of faith. The parting of faith
is that many Christians
they believe that Jesus Christ peace be
upon him claim divinity. Many Christians
believe that Jesus Christ peace be upon
is almighty God. In fact, if you read
the Bible, there is not a single
unequivocal statement, not a single
unambiguous statement anywhere this
Christ peace be upon himself says that I
am God or say worship me. I repeat that
if any Christian
can point out any unequivocal statement
any unambiguous statement from anywhere
in the Bible where Jesus Christ peace be
upon himself says that I am God or where
he says worship me I Dr.
I I'm ready to accept Christianity
today. I'm not speaking on behalf of my
other Muslim brothers and sisters. I'm
putting my head on the guillotine
because I'm a student of pity religion.
And it's a challenge that if anyone can
point out a single unequivocal
statement, a single unambiguous
statement from anywhere in the Bible
where Jesus Christ peace be upon himself
say that I am God or where he says
worship me. I'm ready to accept
Christianity. Now in fact if you read
the Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself said it's mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter number 14 verse
number 28 my father is greater than I.
Gospel of John chapter number 10 verse
number 29 my father is greater than all.
Gospel of Matthew chapter number 12
verse number 28 I cast out devil with
the spirit of God. Gospel of Luke
chapter number 11 verse number 20. I
with the finger of God cast out devil.
Gospel of John chapter number 5 verse
number 30. I CAN OF MY OWN SELF do
nothing. As I hear I judge and my
judgment is just. For I seek not my will
but the will of Almighty God. Anyone who
says I seek not my will but the will of
Almighty God is a Muslim. So Jesus
Christ peace be upon is a Muslim. He
never claimed divinity.
In fact, if you read the Gospel of
Matthew chapter number 5 verse number 17
to 20, Jesus Christ peace be upon him
says, "Think not that I have come to
destroy the law or the prophets. I have
come not to destroy but to fulfill.
Until the heaven and the earth pass
away, not one jot or tit shall pass away
from the law until all be fulfilled. And
whosoever shall break one of the least
commandments will be called least in the
kingdom of heaven. And whosoever shall
keep them will be called great in the
kingdom of heaven. Unless your
righteousness exceeds the righteous of
the scribes and the Pharisees, in no way
shall you enter the kingdom of heaven.
So Jesus Christ peace be upon him says
that if you want to enter Jenna, if you
want to go to paradise, you have to
follow all the laws and commandments
that came before whatever Moses peace be
upon him taught that there is one God.
You don't make image of God, you don't
make any idols of God. If you break one
j of the law, you shall not enter Jenna.
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said it's
mentioned in the gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 24. Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said
the words that you hear are not mine but
my fathers who have sent me. It's
mentioned in the gospel of John chapter
number 17 verse number three. Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said this is
life eternal so that you may know there
is one God and Jesus Christ whom thou I
sent
and it's clearly mentioned in the book
of acts
chapter number 22 verse number two
where Jesus where it is mentioned in the
book of acts chapter number two verse
number 22 that
immen of Israel listen to this Jesus of
Nazareth a man approved of god among
amongst you by wonders and miracles and
signs which God did by him and you are
witness to it. A man
approved of God
amongst you by wonders and miracles and
signs which God did by him and you are
witness to it. And when Jesus Christ
peace be upon asked that which is the
first of the commandment he repeats
verbatim what was said by Moses peace be
upon him. It's mentioned in the gospel
of Mark chapter number 12 verse number
29. Jesus Christ peace be upon him says
in Hebrew
the Lord our God is one Lord. So if you
read the Bible you shall understand
the concept of God in Christianity and
understand Christianity in the right
perspective.